à vous merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rtl françois stéphane rozès
est ce que vous estimez que c'est
clairement un changement de cap pour le
gouvernement en matière de stratégie
vaccinale
oui d'autant qu'il est rare d'entendre
un président de la république semblait
s'agacer des monteurs de son propre
gouvernement car si la stratégie on
imagine que le président qui jusqu'à
maintenant a voulu montrer que c'était
lui qui était aux commandes
au fond a subi une pression sans doute à
la fois de beaucoup de scientifiques
vous l'avez indiqué notamment au travers
de la parole d'axel kahn mais aussi de
critiques de deux secteurs de l'opinion
et puis vous l'avez indiqué des
comparaisons avec nos principaux voisins
qui semble dire qu'à nouveau la france
est à la traîne donc il ya eu un
agacement présidentielle un recadrage et
vont l'expression qui a eu à un nouveau
problème à long terme de gestion
sanitaire et semblant de dire que la
france n'était pas prête à temps alors
où se situe clairement le problème
comment le gouvernement peut à la fois
assumer une certaine lenteur
c'est ce qu'on a compris là
durant la semaine écoulée et puis dans
le même temps donner en quelque sorte un
coup d'accélérateur en avançant de 2
mois sur le calendrier initial la
vaccination des soignants de plus de 50
ans nous avez raison on en est réduit
puisque au fond il n'y a eu aucune
communication gouvernementale
présidentielle clair sur cette campagne
de vaccination il ya eu des bribes
d'arguments on en est réduit à des
hypothèses je peux en avant ces quatre
mais il y en a sans doute d'autres
la première c'est que peut-être y at-il
eu au départ une stratégie nationale
visant à privilégier sanofi qui
finalement n'a pas été au rendez vous en
tout cas immédiat sur un vaccin
française qui aurait pu désorienté au
fond les autorités
la seconde qui a un problème plus
sérieux qui est au fond les autorités
françaises sont mus par un principe de
précaution
en fait il n'ya pas une visibilité très
nette sur les effets des vaccins
notamment celles pour lesquelles il ya
de nouvelles technologies génétiques de
vaccins chez par exemple fatzer et son
partenaire allemand et astrazeneca est
au fond on a entendu dire que la france
aurait pu laisser ses voisins et
partenaires tester en premier pour voir
si d'aventuré en terrain réel
il y aurait des effets secondaires
induits et néfaste le troisième point
moon avait avancé c'est qu'au fond il y
aurait eu un problème de logistique et
de gouvernance en matière de politique
sanitaire
on a été habitué avec la sphère même
grave des mensonges sur les masques
puisqu'on semblait dire qu'il n'était
pas opérant alors tout simplement on en
était pas ce qui évidemment était très
grave
ensuite il ya eu la matrice mme sur la
question des vaccins
et puis une quatrième raison évidemment
toutes ces raisons peuvent être liés
c'est le rapport à l'opinion il est
paradoxal que dans un pays où l'état est
au centre de tout et dans le pays de
pasteur dès lé départ yens défiance des
français il y avait environ la moitié
des français prêts à se faire vacciner
l'autre moitié qui n'était pas donc ça
relevait d' avec départ d'une défiance
d'ailleurs qui remonte des départs de
l'aco vie de 19 défiance à l'égard des
autorités qui a été renforcée et on peut
penser que les gouvernants ont pu être
inquiet des mouvements anti vaccins
s'interrogeant sur le fait de savoir si
le pignon naga pas traîné des pieds
revendiqué alors que tous ceux qui
travaillent sur la communication center
savent qu'en france à partir du moment
où le clap est nette en matière de
politique sanitaire l'opinion suit
l'engagement des gouvernants or la
remarquons qu aucun de nos gouvernants
symboliquement n'a fait ce qui existait
ailleurs j'ai encore une question
j'ai encore une question gabriel at elle
qui a affirmé hier que fin février un
million de vaccins sont administrés ça
est ce que c'est un objectif réalisable
on sait que dans les pharmacies et aussi
parmi les les
les médecins libéraux il ya très peu
d'informations pour l'instant sur
comment ce vaccin doit être administré à
grande échelle 1 millions de vaccins
voilà c'est peu à l'échelle nationale
mais tout de même par rapport à ça
autour d'axés nation aujourd'hui c'est
pas mal quand même je suis un
politologue je suis pas un spécialiste
des politiques sanitaires et même des
communications sanitaire même si dans le
passé
professionnellement j'ai eu à travailler
pour des gouvernants antérieures
l'objectif semble important pourquoi
parce que ça a été dit dès le départ on
voulait en passer par les canaux
traditionnels des médecins les ehpad
alors que d'autres pays notamment
l'allemagne
ont eu des politiques très très
volontaire ou bien nos voisins anglais
dont les chiffres 1 je rappelle que les
anglais ont dès maintenant 1958 vacciner
alors que nous vous l'avez dit on en est
à des chiffres horribles de 300
personnes donc cet objectif semble quand
même difficile à atteindre mais on croit
comprendre qu'après la remontée de
bretelles du président on croit
comprendre qu'après l'accablement des
français sur ce nouveau retard il s'agit
de fixer des objectifs ambitieux pour
que tout le monde comprenne que
maintenant il faut y aller rapidement
merci beaucoup stéphane rozès je
rappelle que vous êtes un politologue
président de la société de conseil cap 1